J'espérais pour le bien de notre pays
que Donald Trump montrerait un certain
intérêt
à prendre le travail au sérieux
, qu'il pourrait en venir à ressentir le poids de
la fonction
et découvrir un certain respect pour la
démocratie
qui lui avait été confiée,
mais il ne l'a jamais fait.
depuis près de quatre ans maintenant, il n'a montré
aucun
intérêt à se mettre au travail aucun
intérêt à trouver un terrain d'entente
aucun intérêt à utiliser le pouvoir impressionnant
de son bureau
pour aider qui que ce soit d'autre que lui-même et ses
amis
aucun intérêt à traiter la présidence
comme autre chose qu'une  plus de télé-réalité
qu'il peut utiliser
pour attirer l'attention dont il a besoin